En este video vamos a hablar sobre figuras y
algo a lo que llamamos ángulos que tal vez hayas
escuchado antes. Entonces, la primera pregunta
es: ¿qué es un ángulo? Bueno, dibujemos una figura
que nos puede ayudar a explicar qué es un ángulo.
Vamos a dibujar un triángulo, y seguramente sabes
que un triángulo tiene tres lados, podemos verlos:
un lado, dos lados, tres lados; pero también tiene
tres ángulos. Ahora, ¿cuáles son los ángulos?
Bueno, en una figura como ésta podemos pensar
un ángulo como el lugar donde se unen dos lados.
Por ejemplo, este de aquí es un ángulo, ya que
dos de los lados se unen aquí, este lado y este
lado se unen en este punto: este es un ángulo,
este de acá es otro ángulo y este es otro ángulo.
Entonces, un triángulo no sólo tiene tres lados,
además tiene tres ángulos. Ahora, déjame hacerte
una pregunta: si dibujamos un rectángulo por aquí,
¿cuántos ángulos tiene? Pausa el video y piénsalo.
Bueno, podemos ver los ángulos: tenemos un
ángulo por aquí, otro por acá, llevamos 2, 3 y 4.
Entonces un rectángulo no sólo tiene cuatro lados,
además tiene cuatro ángulos. Ahora, y si te
diera otra figura de cuatro lados, es decir,
otro cuadrilátero -cuadrilátero es una palabra muy
elegante, pero en realidad sólo significa figura
de cuatro lados-, y si te diera otra figura de
cuatro lados, pero que no fuera un rectángulo,
¿qué tal si te doy otra figura como esta? Este
tipo de cuadrilátero también tiene cuatro lados,
pero podemos ver que se ve un poco distinto a un
rectángulo. Tienen uno, dos, tres, cuatro lados,
y ¿cuántos ángulos tiene? Esta figura se llama
trapecio, ¿cuántos ángulos tiene un trapecio?
Bueno, vamos a contarlos de nuevo: tenemos
un ángulo por aquí, 2, 3 y 4. Entonces, este
cuadrilátero, este trapecio, como el rectángulo,
tiene cuatro lados y cuatro ángulos. Ahora bien,
¿qué pasaría si te pido lo contrario?, si
te pidiera que dibujes una figura; de hecho,
si tienes lápiz y papel te animo a que lo
intentes, intenta dibujar una figura con
cinco ángulos. ¿Conoces el nombre de esa figura?
Bueno, trabajemos juntos. Aquí tenemos un ángulo,
después tenemos dos ángulos, después tenemos
tres ángulos, ahora tenemos cuatro ángulos y,
si regresamos al mismo punto, tenemos cinco
ángulos. Vamos a señalarlos: tenemos uno,
dos, tres, cuatro, cinco ángulos. También
puedes ver que tenemos uno, dos, tres,
cuatro, cinco lados, y ¿cómo llamamos a una
figura de cinco lados? La llamamos pentágono:
entonces tenemos cinco ángulos y cinco
lados. Y, bueno, si tenemos seis ángulos,
¿qué figura tendremos? Bueno, no la vamos a
dibujar; si gustas, puedes dibujarla en el papel,
pero si tiene seis ángulos tendrás un
hexágono, que es una figura de seis lados.